PewDiePie : Hey How is going Bros
My Name is
ahhhh....
AHHHH....
its time
to get even
I'm very excited because today we get to play
the first
Forty minutes exclusively on the Poodiepie channel
honestly
I don't know much about this game
i've just seen snippets and it's the kind of thing where you see and you're like "I HAVE TO PLAY THAT"
This look so cool
So I'm very, very excited
to be playing this for you guys
I don't know what to expect
But I think that's a good thing
So, if you've never heard of this game before
Or even if you have
Let's check it out together
Cause it looks amazing
Let's go
Difficulty, traumatizing
(Wish me luck)
This is gonna go great
Ok
Hey, don't copy me
God, what did I sign
So, this sounds great
(WTF)
What is happening?
What?, celo-
celo-
wr-wait.what?
Ooo
oooo
*what is happening what the shit*
Heyyyy, where-
Wooahh
Dudde
This looks amazing!
So this is an indie type of game
I'm not sure how indie
It seems to be kind of
Weird things these days
But,
Damn, it looks really cool
Black, stay away from the hand over sight, we have the girl, you cannot save her, let this run it's course
Okay
I don't think I need to look at this any more but,
Fine
(Scary door opening sound)
There we go
Whoa
This-
I'm so curious
What the hell is happening?
I thought this would be kind of like a horror game
it's not
sssetting it's
oh okay well
I'm not going to go in that
Oh, nevermind
*ominous rumble sound*
What was that ?
A door get closed behind me?
Where should I possib-
oh, ow
Where should I possibly go?
Hey! It's a car
I can run
Cool graffiti
Ech
What is that sound?
It seems like I have a timer on me
or some shit
Alright
Switch between your weapons
WHAT THE FUCK I HAVE WEAPONS ?!
Ok, why do I have weapons?
Oh my god , are there people here?
OH
Ok, there are
Save the girl
Save the cheerleader
Save the world
Ok, well lets keep it nice
and cool
I don't have a cross hair
I just realized
That's cool, I don't need it
My mouse sensitivity is out of con-
Ah fuck
Tab equips your phone
Why would I need my phone?
Maybe I shouldn't check
Heyyy! It's her!
Damn
Ok, now I know who I need to save
Yeah, she looks like she needs to be saved
Definitely looks like it
Alright, lets take it nice and easy
Okay, it's dark
"Green lights on the side of your phone guide you towards nearby evidence"
Green lights on the side of your phone
Is that the
green light?
Oh, it is
That's cool
I need to find evidence
Hey, it's a drone everybody
It's a drone
We're scanning it
HEY !
What did we find?
It's a drone
Damn, how did my voice get so badass?
Jesus Christ !
Anything else I need to do with that?
I'm happy with my gun by the way
I'm happy to just have my-my gun and shoot people
I feel like a mind fuck is coming up
Do you ever feel like
there's a mind-fuck
about to sneak up on ya' ?
Ok, lets take it nice and
Huya!
Nice and
EUy!
Oh god , I'm sorry
I panicked
Oh god
There will be military people
What the fuck?
Where are we?
There's smoke here
HHHuu
their near by
Okie
There's evidence here
Should we scan for it?
I guess the smoke, yea
Ok, let's check it out
The tension is building
Shh
God damn it Siri
I think I'll
I think
this gun
thing
uh wait
this
THIS gun
Thank you
Better keep quiet
Yeah , say that out loud.
Oh shit
There he is
Stealth
Stealth take down
Hell ya mother fucka
Got 'em
GOT 'em, I'll be taking this
So this is where I am
That's cool
So we're getting near them now
Ok, they're a floor up
Okay , let's try and get up
The stairs are over here
Here we go . Okay
I don't know where we're goin'
But I don't like it !!
Oh , here we go
Alright
This should be.. coming up
Ok
Great
This is...
*weird noise*
What the Fuck are You Talking about
umm... okay
Well Here's the Plant
and uh...
There is a... Compu...
There's
Co...
What...?
*Theme Song*
umm...
*Theme Song and Kids Noise*
What? Seven?
*theme song*
OMG
Five
*theme song*
This is So Weird
i Love the Music is so Nice <33
Seven Five Nine
Could it Be One More?
*theme song*
Who The Fuc...?
That's a Nice Dog
Four
*theme song*
HEYY :D
The Mind Has a Funny Way of Remembering Things
That Was True
Hey...it's a New Router
*typing keyboard sound*
YES
We're Hacking in...
OH MY
GOD
ssshhhh....
Siri Please
You Don't Need to Guilt Me Alright?
Just do...Confi....
Good Ol' Corner Gun
My Best Friend
is That?
What is Distance
oOoOoooOO
it's Building Up
OWWHUU
Alright :D
Corner Gun Left
Corner Gun RIGHT
*reloading*
HELL YEAA
UHHHHHH
This is a Really... Really Intresting New game
I'm
i
i Really Enjoy it
i Hope you Did as Well :D
if You Have Fun
Ha.. Leave a...
LIKE
PewDiePie Plays Games Everyone
*claps*
i Love PewDiePie Plays Games (i Hope you Play Outlast 2 on April 25 :D)
is...
*laughing*
That's All I'm Allow to Play for Now
Mabye i'le Check Out the Full game
When it Come Out
Let Me Know if You Want me to Do That
and As Always...
*kiss brofist*
STAY AWESOME